gaucher disease is a rare genetic
disorder which is also known as a
lysosomal storage Disorder so obviously
the lysosome is involved and there is an
accumulation of glucose cerebrocyte
which accumulates because the enzyme
that breaks down it doesn't work
properly
leukocerebrosidase enzyme is encoded by
GBA Gene which is present in chromosome
1 in a mutation where glucose
cerebrosidase activity is gone glucose
cerebrocytes accumulates because it
cannot be broken down that's the disease
pathology and it accumulates in the
lysosome inside the macrophages which
gives them a crumpled tissue paper like
appearance and these are known as
grossier cells
this is a pathological Hallmark there
are different types of gaussian disease
type 2 involves the nervous system but
type 1 don't
type 1 involves hepatosplinomegaly just
to name few symptoms type 2 involves
seizure and other neurological
complications like motor skill problem
decreased muscle tone Etc
it can be detected using serum based
enzyme test